[Music]
all right well now do your exclusive
sit-down with Demi Lovato I love this
woman so much she is the epitome of
confidence these days and her brand new
YouTube documentaries simply complicated
proves that she's sorry not sorry for
the journey that got her there I just
feel like I have the bigger purpose than
just singing and I want to make sure
that I use what I have for for good
everything happened so fast
Demi's new doc is real and raw I'm
coming up on five and a half years of
sobriety so weird to talk about this on
camera
seven minutes you look at the camera and
you say I was 17 the first time I tried
cocaine and I loved it how how did you
find that bravery in yourself when I
said that and I looked in the camera and
I said that I loved it is like that's
the type of honesty that people need to
hear in order to protect themselves from
possibly going down that road because
drugs and alcohol is so tempting I went
on like a bender like two months when I
was using daily I want to prevent my
fans from going through the things that
I went through I'm on a journey to
discover what it's like to be free of
all demons Demi is so passionate about
helping others live a better life she's
now co-owner of the treatment center she
credits with getting her silver I
actually was in fasteners when I went to
sober living so I started out as a
patient there and I now co-owned it so
it's kind of come full circle and I feel
kind of like a therapist at times I
think it's really cool that I get to be
hands-on and they get to be totally
honest with these people and and help
them out in the best way that I possibly
can and if life gets a little
complicated
Demi's found the perfect retreat I do
have a huge love for Brazilian Jujitsu
it's like it's a new passion of mine
do you think you could tap out Nick
Jonas yes absolutely
hundred percent one under birthday